das ist sogar noch Schauspieler Schüler
machen wollen
erstmalig keine Karriere
also es ist und diesem Begriff mit dem
ich überhaupt nichts anfangen kann
was ich noch machen will Schauspieler
Baywatch
ich habe da keine Visionen all soll das
Erbe
Dallas
ein paar Monaten vorbei ist kann aus
seiner Sicht wäre
drei Jahre Daten zu machen der Richtung
also
ich hatte gar nicht besonders
ambitioniert
ich wurde dann
einfach für mich persönlich was machen
experimentieren Kindern schreiben und
ihn ein Spiel
sowas lässt als das Internet und so
also ich will in die Sendung berichtet
für Maren Krampe und versorgt es zieht
mich nicht